cinq fois détentrice du record mondial
féminin de vitesse dans les années 50
jacqueline auriol a marqué le monde de
l'aviation elle est la première femme
pilote d'essais de france ça se passait
au ceb de brétigny à l'époque et donc il
n'y avait pas encore tous les
ordinateurs et donc les avions étaient
testés en réalité pas sur des
ordinateurs
donc on fait tous les tests à partir
d'avions et donc elle était dans les
pilotes d'essais donc les fallait qu
elle est une formation d'ingénieur si
vous voulez parce qu'après dans les i
c'est vous avez un compte rendu à faire
des explications à des professionnels et
donc elle est partie sur des petits
avions et elle a terminé sur les avions
de chasse une figure incontournable
comme toutes les femmes présentées ici à
elancourt ces panneaux retracent leur
histoire des pionnières aux astronautes
des métiers autrefois réservés aux
hommes
une exposition mise en place par michel
bond enseigne est ancienne compétitrice
là je suis dans la tenue de l'avion sur
lequel j'ai fait les championnats de
france de voltige et là je suis en photo
devant et broad où j'ai gagné le premier
prix du rallye du dauphiné on a le
sentiment d'avoir encore des gens qui
pensent que c'est accessible aux femmes
avec cette exposition on essaie de la
faire circuler dans toute la france pour
bien faire voir que il ya de tout et que
c'est ouvert à tout le monde
selon son association aujourd'hui les
femmes ne représentent que 7% des
pilotes professionnels la conquête des
droits des femmes passe aussi par la
conquête du ciel